Hey Thoughty2 here.
Everybody loves.
Every single person at some point has that
small moment of bliss that changes the rest
of their life.
And we’re not the only ones, even animals
have fully monogamous relationships.
Look they cuddle and everything.
But what exactly is love?
Let’s finally answer the question that’s
perplexed scientists for generations.
Oh and if you stay long enough I might even
tell you how you can make someone love you.
Love is free, it can’t be owned, bought
or sold.
Is has no mass or weight and cannot be touched.
Yet it is the single most powerful emotion
humans can experience.
It makes us do some really stupid stuff sometimes.
But it’s far more than an emotion, it can
physically affect our bodies in some rather
incredible ways.
For example, some extraordinary research revealed
that when two lovers gaze into each others
eyes, their heart rates synchronise and beat
at the exact same time.
This graph shows the heart rates of two individuals
in love, whilst their eyes were locked in
a loving exchange.
The red line shows one heart beat, the blue
line the other, notice how their heart rates
are so closely matched, so much so, that the
blue line can barely be seen beneath the red
line.
Love is also a powerful pain killer.
In fact, cuddling can cure a headache, during
a loving embrace the chemical Oxytocin is
released in our brains, ovaries and testicles.
Research has found that a dose of Oxytocin
can significantly decrease headaches and other
pains.
Studies have also shown that simply looking
at a photo of a loved one can reduce pain
by up to 40%.
So then, what is love?
Well, this really depends on how you look
at it, some people say love is down to fate,
our path is already decided, out of our control.
That sure sounds poetic, but the processes
associated with love can actually be extrapolated
and explained to a large extent by science.
But I should warn you, this won’t be romantic,
unless statistics turn you on.
Psychologists have shown that it takes anywhere
between 90 seconds and 4 minutes to decide
if you fancy someone.
Surprisingly being attracted to someone has
very little to do with what they say, research
shows that 55% is through body language, 38%
is the tone and speed of their voice and only
7% is down to what they say.
In order to properly explain love we must
first break it down into its 3 stages, lust,
attraction and attachment.
Each stage is driven by its own set of unique
hormones and chemicals.
A person must go through all 3 stages before
they can truly be in love with someone, which
kind of puts a spanner in the whole “love
at first sight” thing.
The first stage, Lust is probably the most
biologically simple, lust is driven by the
sex hormones testosterone and oestrogen.
In fact research shows that women actually
have different tastes in men whilst using
contraception.
Women taking the pill prefer men with more
feminine faces, whereas women not using contraception
prefer more masculine men.
But what’s even more interesting is that
the features that trigger lust in a person
differs between genders.
Research shows that men are attracted to women
that have a symmetrical face, full lips, full
breasts, and wide hips compared to their waist
size, or to put in more simply an hourglass
figure.
Because statistically curvy women are also
the most fertile.
In fact there’s actually some maths behind
this, in European countries the most desirable
waist-to-hip ratio in women is 0.7, and in
South America and Africa it’s 0.9.
On the other hand, women prefer men with broad
shoulders and a narrow waist.
But most intriguingly, one of the most desirable
qualities in a man is a healthy immune system.
Research shows that women are subconsciously
attracted to men with healthy faces, because
this signals a strong immune system.
Stage 2 is Attraction, this is the stage when
you’re deeply in love and you can’t think
of anything but your new partner.
Scientists think there are three main neurotransmitters
involved with this stage, adrenaline, dopamine
and serotonin.
Firstly, adrenaline along with the stress
hormone cortisol are released in your body
during the first few weeks of your new relationship.
These two chemicals are responsible for making
you sweat, increasing your heart rate and
giving you a dry mouth when you’re around
your new love interest.
Secondly, your levels of dopamine increase,
this gives you an intense rush of pleasure
when you bump into your new love and it’s
what makes you desire them even more.
Increased dopamine levels also increase your
energy levels, and decrease your need for
sleep and food.
It actually has a very similar effect on the
brain as taking cocaine.
And finally, whilst you’re in the attraction
stage, your levels of the serotonin neurotransmitter
drop dramatically.
This causes you to become obsessed with your
new love interest, it’s the reason they
keep popping into your thoughts throughout
the day.
Interestingly the low serotonin levels experienced
by new lovers are remarkably similar to the
low serotonin levels found in patients with
Obsessive-Compulsive Disorder.
Lastly, the final and most important stage
of love is attachment.
During this stage the powerful bond is formed
that keeps some couples together for life
and makes them want to have children.
Research shows there are two major hormones
responsible for this feeling of attachment.
Oxytocin and vasopressin.
Both the oxytocin and vasopressin hormones
are released by men and women, when they kiss,
cuddle and have sex.
Scientists believe that the more sex a couple
has, the deeper their bond becomes.
An interesting example of this can be seen
with prairie voles.
Like humans, they indulge in far more sex
than is necessary for the purpose of reproduction,
and they also, like humans, form stable pair-bonds.
As part of an experiment, scientists gave
prairie voles a drug that suppresses the effect
of the vasopressin hormone.
Something remarkable happened, their bond
with their partner deteriorated immediately
and they no longer protected their partner
from potential new suitors.
So in a nutshell, the answer to the question
“What is love?”, is “Love is a state
of deep attachment to a fellow human being,
caused by a combination of chemicals.
Specifically: Testosterone, Oestrogen, Adrenaline,
Dopamine, Serotonin, Oxytocin and Vasopressin”.
Sounds so romantic doesn’t it?
I do apologise if I’ve somewhat ruined the
magic.
But remember, these are nothing more than
scientific explanations for a set of symptoms
and behaviours associated with being in love.
In reality, love truly is a seemingly magical
and rather beautiful, force of nature that
could never be fully explained by science.
But there’s still the question of “why”
does love exist, what purpose does it serve?
Evolutionary scientists believe that love
is a product of evolution.
The theory goes like this.
Without love acting as the glue, in a relationship,
keeping a partner long enough to reproduce
is difficult.
If love wasn’t a component in most relationships,
they most likely wouldn’t last longer than
a couple of weeks.
Which, means a lot fewer couples would reproduce.
It’s love, that keeps relationships together
for several years or more, long enough for
them to have children, which, after all is
the ultimate goal of evolution.
Scientists believe that over millions of years,
humans, and certain other animals, have developed
a specific set of chemical processes, to make
us feel like we are emotionally attached to
our potential mating partner.
Thus giving us an incentive to want to stay
together and ultimately reproduce.
We, however, interpret this, as being in love.
But you may be thinking, if the sole purpose
of love is just an incentive to reproduce.
Then why do we love our family, and even our
pets?
It all has to do with the attachment hormone
we talked about before, Oxytocin.
It isn’t just released when we have sex,
it’s also released in somewhat smaller doses
when we simply touch another person, or animal.
Every time we touch another person and experience
a release of Oxytocin, we become more deeply
attached to them.
And who do you think you came in contact with
the most as a baby, that’s right, your family.
Ever heard the phrase “There’s nothing
like a mother’s love”.
Well there really isn’t, during the later
stages of pregnancy Oxytocin levels in the
mother surge to unfathomably high levels,
these levels peak right at the moment of childbirth.
This creates a seemingly unbreakable bond
and an unrivalled level of attachment between
the mother and child.
But it’s not just humans that release Oxytocin.
Scientists have discovered that dogs and cats,
among many other animals, also release Oxytocin
when they come into physical contact with
another animal, or human.
So good news animal lovers, this means, that
your pet really does love you too.
Scientists found that the more you socially
interact with your pet, the more deeply they
become attached to you, and hence the more
deeply they will fall in love with you.
So then, like I promised here’s how you
can make someone fall in love with you.
It’s really quite simple, find a potential
new suitor, it doesn’t even have to be someone
you know.
Reveal some intimate details about your life
to them, then stare deeply into their eyes
for 4 minutes.
There’s a slight chance you may get a slap,
but research shows that more often than not
they will feel strangely attracted to you.
New York psychologist, Professor Arthur Arun,
demonstrated this when he randomly paired
people together from a group of complete strangers
and asked them to reveal intimate details
about their lives to each other for 30 minutes,
then stare deeply into each other’s eyes
for 4 minutes.
Afterwards nearly all of the couples admitted
to feeling deeply attracted to the stranger,
whom they had only spent 34 minutes with.
And following the experiment one of the couples
actually got married.
If for some weird reason you don’t feel
comfortable imposing your newly learned Jedi
mind tricks on a complete stranger.
Fear not, there are some slightly less insane
things you can do to increase the chances
of your crush falling in love with you.
Research shows that proximity has a huge effect
on love.
A study in Ohio showed that 54% of couples
who recently applied for marriage licenses
were separated by a distance of 16 blocks
or fewer and 37% were less than 5 blocks apart
from each other.
The science behind this is repeated exposure.
The more you see someone or something the
more you like it.
However this is not always the case, repeated
exposure to another person amplifies the dominant
emotion in the relationship.
So if the dominant emotion is anger or hate,
they’re just going to dislike you even more.
But the bottom-line is, if you want someone
to fall in love with you, you should spend
as much time as possible in their company.
Unless you really, really annoy them.
Research shows that individuals whom are in
a state of emotional distress are significantly
more likely to fall in love.
This state of emotional unease is often found
following the death of a loved one, being
in an accident, or most commonly, after a
painful breakup.
Obstacles that stand in the way of love can
actually increase the chance of a relationship
forming.
Studies show that attraction is actually increased
when external factors get in the way.
A great example of this is when teenagers
start a relationship and their parents object,
it only makes the teenagers want to be together
even more.
Finally, I’ll leave you with these facts.
Women tend to find men twice as attractive
when they notice other women are interested
in him.
Also, on average, a man will spend one year
of his life staring at women.
It’s also common to think that men are less
emotionally affected by relationships than
women.
But statistically, men are quicker than women
to say “I love you” in relationships and
contrary to popular belief, recent studies
have shown that men are more emotionally affected
when a relationship ends than women.